hey everybody and welcome to a methed up
wild ride with steo we've got poopies
and the good news is he is now clean and
sober the bad news Well we are going to
hear a lot of that he has been through
the ringer and you know who else went
through the ringer my lady my lady Lux I
put her through a lot a lot a lot on my
multimedia comedy special The Bucket
List which is of course now available at
sto.com you would be out of your mind
not to see how crazy that is but back to
poopies he's arguably even more lovable
than ever and man he's more poopies than
ever so let's get into it people of the
Universe I bring you poopies oh yeah
what's up and this is your first time in
the
van the other time we had you on the
Wild Ride podcast you were on the tour
bus yep and you were doing standup
comedy with us y that was so much fun
where was that pen uh I know that we had
him in uh
Missouri Missouri and we were in um Ohio
Indiana Indiana I think Indiana we did
the podcast that was right after the
like the jousting right yeah the Jing
was sick that was we did our podcast at
2 a.m. right wow yeah we did it after
your show was a long day okay have you
done have you done standup since um yeah
I actually went to the did one at the
Improv in Orange County nice yeah but
what the Irvine Improv yeah I don't
really remember it though cuz I was
freaking I wasn't sober it was back in
the day back so we might as well break
the news the poopies has become clean
and sober yep yep and you recently
celebrated nine months of sobriety so
awesome and you take sobriety very
seriously yeah I do I have to fight for
my sobriety every day and steo you a big
big help in my
sobriety wow steo actually made a phone
call I showed up to
meeting and I was like steo I need help
I
need I need you know I cuz I was like
living at my friends I got out of the
U-Haul living at my friends yeah let's
explain what was going on with the
U-haul you were uh living in a U-Haul
truck yeah living in a U-Haul truck um
smoking smoking crystal math all right
and I don't mean to laugh but that's
pretty funny yeah no it's not funny but
it's gnarly it was gnarly and yeah I
kind of just like didn't really care
about anything except my addiction and
you know kind of wasn't surfing wasn't
hanging out with my friends just wasn't
filming
YouTube kind of just went down that
really dark path of addiction and thank
God I'm freaking sober now I I can't
believe like I never thought like
getting sober was
like fun you know and it's like I'm so
much happier
now like I don't know it's hard to
explain you got to really like do it to
understand you know I I understand but
yeah everything like life is so much
better like I have a great apartment and
I moved to pad Del re yep and I got a
great apartment with my amazing
girlfriend Hannah May and yeah yeah now
I'm I'm almost 10 months sober on the
7th y so yeah how long ago did he do our
our podcast when when was that maybe
like a year ago like a year so then you
had like two months after that podcast
where you just went ape [__] yeah I got
yeah I think
um yeah when I got home cuz I after the
tour after your tour I was kind of like
withdrawing and I got home and just like
from what withdrawing from what from
drugs and alcohol have you been um
candid about the time when I think uh
jackass was still being filmed and you
uh ended up like almost dying like
ambulance to the hospital with the fenel
overdose oh yeah that was gnarly I was
trying to keep that like no one find out
about that but yeah it was well they're
going to find out about it now we we can
just move on and cut it out if you want
I don't know yeah I mean whatever do
what do you care yeah I mean part of
your story yeah it's part of the story
for sure um and how did that happen as I
I it was our last weekend filming and
you were trying to do a little bit of
snipple snacks yeah I was trying to do a
little bit of sniffy snack little sneaky
snack some below Yeah by that we we mean
the the powder cocaine Y and um I
actually went and saw Rachel wolson
doing standup up on top of this garage
and it was our last weekend in the in
the hotels um in um Universal City and I
was like [__] I'm just going to I went
back to my hotel and I was like [__]
it's my last night here you know I want
to go out and Park
and I went out to freaking um CBO Grill
and there's this huge line and I was
hammered off wine you know that was
before I got addicted to to the bad
stuff but um yeah and I was hammered on
wine I was like [__] I need something to
wake me up and I asked this like random
person on the street for some cocaine
and they gave like I had like 40 bucks
and they gave me like half a gram and I
took two key bumps in the line and all
of a sudden I was freaking I woke up in
the ambulance oh [__] yeah and luckily I
was like wrapping it out with these
people in front of me these super cool
black chicks and like I think they um
called the ambulance or called 911
what's the last thing you remember just
doing a couple key bumps and then it
kind of just went blurry and then I saw
I went to like the darkest like you know
when you cover your eyes and then like
and then you keep laying ing it and it
gets darker and darker that's what I saw
like the darkest darkest
color and I was like what the [__]
what's going on you know and I was dead
did your heart stop yeah they had a
freaking put the freaking theor the pads
on you no they didn't shock me the Nar
the narcans I had I woke up with narcans
in my
chest Jesus and I was like they're like
he's
alive wow he's alive
yeah and then I went to they took me to
the Hollywood P Presbyterian
Presbyterian church and I was like it
was like 4:00 a.m. and I was like [__] I
got to get out of here like I can't let
anyone find out I'm pretty sure they
didn't take you to a church or yeah not
the church the hospital he's like the
Hollywood perspiration church this boy
needs to pray yeah yeah I needed that
too but yeah and then I snuck out of the
hospital like down and everything yeah I
got a I got a uber out of there go uhhuh
with no underwear on no just I'm trying
to remember who told on you for that
like cuz yeah cuz I called Rachel and I
was like Rachel I freaking just ODed
then like that morning you know and then
maybe Rachel told everybody yeah I think
so I don't yeah I don't know was that
your first time oding yeah was so scary
and I'm such a dumbass too cuz when I
went back home I started doing blow
again too how soon not the same bag
no how soon did you start doing blow
probably that La next weekend that's how
bad my addiction was with drugs jeez
when did it go to math [__] when I was
looking for blow at this one bar and
this guy's like this guy's like I don't
have any blow but I got this were were
you in Hawaii no I was in Carl's Bad you
never did any ice in Hawaii um I tried
it like once or twice but I didn't
really get addicted you know is meth and
Ice the same thing yeah yeah I think ice
is just somehow like a gnarlier version
of it it's so bad it's so bad but it's
so addicting you know like once you try
it and you get a taste of it like you
don't you just want more and more so
this time like you had the whole bag so
you got to use it but then you like went
home with some or something so you this
guy said he has he's like no but I got
this and it was a some meth and he was
he smokes it so we went to his car and I
took like a little you know he like held
it for me lit it for me I didn't know
how to do any of that [__] and then like
the next day dude I stayed up all night
and [__] and the next day
like I called him up cuz he went home
and I called him up I was like hey can I
come over you know and he's like yeah
come over so then it just like I kept
coming over to his house and he kept
freaking feeding it to me [__] then did
he start selling it to you no so he he
just kept letting me use his pipe and
stuff and then like I and just hung out
with him all day cuz I was just wanted
to freaking what city in Carl's bed huh
and I'd hide out in his house cuz I
didn't want anyone to see me all [__]
up on math and [__] and like and then
he's like all right dude you got to
[__] stop bugging me like here's the
here's the plugs number and like here's
where you go get your
pipe and then I [__]
became yeah yeah yeah what a bro and
then I became officially a tweaker and I
like despise tweakers dude and I became
one it's heavy when you were leaving the
hospital you worried production would
find out like you worried you'd get
fired off the mve CU I didn't want any
any of you know the crew members or my
friends to find out you know yeah cuz I
think they would just be super pissed
and like look down on me andless I don't
know I just like felt like they'd be
bummed so what was the reaction cuz
everybody did find
out um so they didn't really tell me
they found out until like I got in
trouble with something and then like
actually steo was like [__] you
[__] OD and [__] and then oh well
yeah cuz I was mad at you because we uh
brought you to one of my shows on my
tour oh yeah my stupid [__] friend
signed the wall he wasn't the only one
to sign it you sign it too what whatever
it doesn't matter but we put you in an
Uber I don't think I don't know I don't
think so we we ordered you an Uber home
Uber home like Scott got like his a
notification we had a paid for a
cleaning fee yeah I was hitting my my
weed pin I think yeah alol and I yeah I
had a beer in
there bad it was just bad yeah was super
disrespectful like Scott was like we use
this Uber for business stuff and you're
trying to get our account shut down and
like you're acting a fool and your
buddy's like vandalizing the the venue
and and like you know it was just kind
of a bummer but like stuff like that was
pretty common where like if you're going
to invite poop somewhere then you know
that's kind of like what would happen
got to say that really was always a very
safe bet and in the future there is a
new safe bet from a new sponsor of the
Wild Ride podcast which I'm happy to
tell you that I've been using for almost
an entire decade
this sponsor is Shopify and no matter
what stage of business you're in even if
it's just starting out with a website
Shopify will get you to the next level
it does it all website no matter what
you're selling even if it's got nothing
to do with physical merchandise maybe
you're selling tickets to an event and
that's all it is just sell the ticket
and and maybe you've got uh video on
demand service and there's no physical
mer Shopify any form of physical mer
anything you can possibly sell Shopify
is the way to do it Shopify is what I
use and again it's how you take your
business to the next level plus they've
got a great deal for you which is that
you can have a $1 a month trial period
if you go to shopify.com
SLO that all has to be in lowercase
letters again shopify.com
sto and why would you do this because
maybe it's time to get that website
maybe it's time to launch that business
and if you have the business maybe it's
time to take it more seriously and bump
it up to the next level again Shopify is
how you do that so shopify.com steo for
the $1 per month trial period and let's
get back to it yeah that was at the same
time that all all this was going on with
like the OD and The Improv yeah maybe
like a couple months after yeah it was
all around the same time there was
another time where uh you guys were
promoting um jackass forever uh with the
UFC oh yeah that was bad you were like
there's an open bar we're in Dana
White's freaking Lounge was that in
Vegas when you came out and you doing
the crane he's like trying to pant Dana
White at the UFC yeah I freaking I did
you get him off no I mean I think he was
just kind of Faking I was like air air
pants you know but I still got up out of
my seat and went over there and was like
trying to be cool and like impress
Knoxville and the boys and [__] and like
check this out and [__] like air
paned them I didn't touch him but I was
like and they're like what the [__] are
you doing dude yeah it was bad dude yeah
open bar at freaking Dana White's Lounge
and then like the happy Dad or the nek
boys were there so I was all pumped
Steve will do it like [__] we're
doing like shotgunning happy dads and
[__] and I felt so bad because like I
asked ponti's uh wife
um I was like hey can you film this real
quick and it's me and me and Steve will
do it [__] shotgunning happy dads and
like and ponnie's like what the [__] are
you doing dude like my wife's not a
filmer you know oh wow wow yeah I think
Pontius had kind of reached a point that
night where he was over me
d i was sloppy
drunk yeah it was it was I'm so glad I'm
out of that like [__] [__] dude cuz I
was just pissing people off and
disrespecting
situations and just being a cook you
know how about Shark Week too Shark Week
to got hammered I mean hammerhead shark
here here's what I heard cuz I was the
on the plane I wasn't on I was on the
first Jackass sh I did not go on the
second jackass sh you been pissed I
heard I heard that um on the flight
there maybe there's like a layover or
something or or like but like at the
airport flying to it poopies is just
getting obliterated in the airport and
then like getting on the airplane like
blaring like speakers like vaping like
blow
the huge clouds of Vape smoke like like
like going like he's like trying to get
kicked off the plane and like everybody
this is like a production you know like
like no regard for if he gets kicked off
the plane like his contract to do the
show how's he going to get there like
funny it's like now that is some steo
[__] big time back in the day and then
uh and then when they were at Shark Week
like poopies didn't like you didn't have
money and you were like hey like can I
like like I borrow some money or like
some they they you didn't have a credit
card to put down for the hotel room yeah
I didn't have a credit card so shaa like
let me use her credit C sh puts the
credit card down and I wasn't going
downstairs for dinners I was just
getting room service she's like do not
abuse this card and then sure enough
when they check out of the hotel room
poopies has like racked up like some
crazy
800 bucks and I was like tripping too I
was like what the [__] cuz there's this
one night
where there's this one night where I
like stayed in and then like all of a
sudden there's like another big Bill on
there and I was like what happened yeah
you couldn't remember yeah I couldn't
remember cuz you're were drunk
yeah and then like I went up to the desk
and I was like yeah like um I don't
remember like spending all this money
and they like took some of the money off
oh wow and Shauna was pissed she was
pissed I remember and dude I felt like I
was in it was the worst like thing ever
cuz you I'm we're supposed to be having
a good time and everyone's pissed at me
and dude I was like [__] dude what the
[__] did I do well you were having a
good time not when everyone got pissed
at me yeah cuz when everyone's pissed at
me I'm I'm just bummed you know so we
painted a picture of what it was like
yeah yeah you don't want me freaking
drinking and and then what happened was
uh I reached out to somebody I know who
who owns and runs a reab and yeah but
why did you reach out did you call him
and say you need help or did you what
was the last day like for you like why
did you I think out cuz like I was in my
friend's um House Brandon glade's house
um in a detox like a residential detox
cuz he's been through the program and
stuff and like he's he's like Mentor
like one of our mentors and I was doing
good and then New Year's came around and
I freaking relapsed and then he's like
dude you got to [__] figure [__] out
dude like so I went to with Tommy I went
to uh AA
meeting you're not wait why is this it's
anonymous anonymous I'm sorry cut that
out that crucial second a i relapsed on
New Year's and then I went
to a place in
Salo wait wait wait what what you how'
you relapse on New Year's what what
happened [__] I don't know I got a like
argument with my girlfriend and then
like we never ended up meeting up and
then then you just went off the rails y
yeah so then we like we we encountered
each other at this Gathering and uh and
and what what you had like some funny
Rock Bottom you described like I
uh what was it like um you couldn't
afford a lighter or something like that
or like what oh my rock bottom story
yeah yeah I was in San
Jose and this guy took off with my
U-Haul which was my
home
and and then I I I didn't have my um
debit card cuz it in the U-Haul so I was
using my phone to pay for things and so
my phone died and I had to beg for
change on this at the gas station in San
Jose and that's where I was like what
was it that you were trying to buy that
you had a phone charger a phone that's
what it was not a lighter a phone he was
like I couldn't afford a phone charger I
had to beg for change to buy a phone
charger and that was a bridge too far
for poopies yeah that was when poopies
was ready to accept help yep for sure
and then I finally got back to Carl's
bad and then went to this Gathering and
saw Ste was like ste's like all right if
I make this call for you you got to do
it like
110% I was like yes I'll do it like I'll
do anything you know MH cuz it gotten so
bad and so you got scholar shipped into
a dope rehab yep can I mention the rehab
I think you can Pace Academy Pace
Academy yep they helped me out huge and
steo like freaking saved me it was all
my buddy Lenny yep Lenny dude he's the
man Lenny from P he's he's taking in a
number of people who uh I I asked him to
so awesome I won't I won't name anybody
else but uh out of everybody I think
that you really put the most into it
yeah like and you you've been cleaning
sober ever since yep yeah I put so much
work in like
therapy just dude so much like I
remember when I was like oh I don't know
if I can do 90 days you know and then I
had to talk with Tommy and then I yeah I
was like I want to do the days like I
get to do the 90 days you know that's
right man like I you got to take
advantage of these 90 days cuz you're
not going to have another chance you
know it's like it's kind of expensive
going into those rehabs you know how
about that poopies has taken advantage
of his opportunities to become a better
version of himself and I got a way that
you can do the very same thing and it is
called whoop what's whoop it's this band
I wear on my wrist it's the most
sophisticated Fitness tracking device
known to man and it tells me all kinds
of stuff about what's going on with my
health my rest my recovery my fitness
how much activity I'm doing and if I'm
honest uh I'm not doing a lot of
activity because I tore my Meniscus and
so I'm uh really really knowing about
how much I'm not moving my body but
that's part of the deal man you got to
know what's going on with your body and
if you want to get to another level in
your Fitness with your recovery your
rest all the rest of it then take
advantage of this opportunity to be a
better version of yourself by going to
whoop.com that's
w.com and use the promo code steo to get
10% off at checkout that's 10% off this
membership that is going to give you all
kinds of insight into becoming a better
you one last time that is whoop.com and
use the promo code steo for 10% off at
checkout now let's get back to it for
sure not when it's free yeah well I'll
you know that's my one chance you know
right right right right right right so
yeah I I ended up like freaking being a
good influence on other other kids in
there too and like I I got that I got I
got regular
reports about uh like updates about how
you were doing yeah it was it was yeah
it was awesome dude I freaking did a lot
of work on myself a lot of work so now
I'm not the the shitty drunk poopies
anymore I'm like that's good man one of
the gnarliest stories I ever heard of
you I think you even said it on one of
your podcasts I couldn't believe that
you did this but you used to he used to
[__] take bong loads of flies for
like five bucks yeah yeah the the
$5 yeah yeah flies he dead flies out of
the window seal and he would just snap
them it tasted really
metallicy that's heavy
dude I mean it's hardly the heaviest
thing we've heard tonight but it is kind
of heavy no I mean well an extra five
bucks if you snap four smoke meth than
[__] take a rip of a fly dude right
no you don't no you not no yeah it did
it it always made me feel really good
and happy and grateful to get these
updates that you were taking everything
so seriously that you were really
putting in the work and you know to hear
from you and and to just see you become
a better version of yourself yeah it
means the world to me dude like I'm
happy for you I'm proud of you and um
you got a girlfriend you've been
traveling places with her y y you were
in Tahiti yep just was in Tahiti a month
ago you jumped on Cameo yeah let's talk
about Cameo Cameo yeah I was [__]
psyched when I was getting cameos on my
serve trip I was like yeah this is
paying for some some dinners and stuff
so I was stoked what was the decision to
go on Cameo with the name Shawn
mackinery versus poopies I don't even
know like was it Shan mcinerney yeah oh
cuz when I looked at it it would say
poopies so yeah if you in like jackass
uhhuh Sean mcinery pops up oh really
that's that's that's not going to bring
in anything so I thought like you got
sober and like you didn't want to be
called poopies anymore so you're sort of
establishing yourself as Sean Macker no
let me check my Cameo is that uh how you
pronounce your last name maer yeah maer
I don't even want to know
that yeah I don't even I don't take back
I take back that question I I I refuse
to see now it's it's on yeah there you
go on poopies yeah poopies and we had a
little fun making a video where we were
asking celebrities to say and do
terrible things on Cameo yeah I just
watched the video it's so funny is that
video going up the same time is this is
going out so they can watch it um yeah
after this right they can go watch it
after this is I I believe that this is
out it it is out yes it's out we steo
uploaded it tonight it's one of the
funniest videos I've seen in a long
[__] time D it's so great it's kind
of embarrassing now that I like watching
it like the poop one like that's the one
that's embarrassing for you it's so
funny we always ask people like how do
they feel about it's like everyone has a
different like issue with it you know
and you're like the poop I don't know
nobody else had a problem with the poop
yeah no cool yeah but it's a banger yeah
and as people listen to this we strongly
urge you to get on Cameo and order a
video from poopies I can vouch for the
fact that poopies will do
anything he will say anything uh but
please don't ask him to pull out his his
wiener yeah no more nudity no more
nudity cuz that will get him suspended
again God I felt awful when we got you
suspended oh it's all good do not pull
out your wiener on Cameo yeah no ever
again well because I got a warning email
oh yeah I think that was from the poop
one because you had yeah yeah your like
dick and balls were like hang from the
firefighter one cuz I did that one at my
apartment in P Del firefighter one would
have been the warning and then the poop
one the poop one cuz I got the good
angle on the poop one it was like you
were already as you were talking oh dude
I had when the video starts like hey
guys this like like already trying to
like work it out um I mean dude and in
the video I said that you know we
requested poopies like take a dump on
his
pants and that we got the video back
from poopies the the request was
fulfilled within 30 minutes like that's
not a joke oh yeah I woke up and like I
seen this Cameo and I was like yeah I
was like I told Hannah I was like babe I
got another Cameo and she's like what is
it this time and I was like you're going
to like this one and he's like I don't
even I'm not filming this one yeah but
the funniest part about that is you in
Tahiti with your girlfriend like just
taking a [__] on a pair of pants in your
room in Tahiti well so we were in a
treehouse Bungalow so the bathroom was
downstairs yeah so luckily um I you know
it wasn't in my my room that I was
staying in but it was in like the
kitchen cuz like there's the communal
kitchen or was it just your guys kitchen
it was like so there's a tree house it
was a communal
kitchen
no it wasn't communal I was the only one
staying there but that would have been
[__] it's like a hostile you know just
like in the funeral request were you
like wow these people like really want
me to say this to my grandmother yeah I
truly believe that I was her last laugh
yeah like you guys did a good job yep we
really did and I'm so Gable dude like no
and and I was just like oh okay well so
um now uh like we love I love that that
video it it urges people to order cameos
from you have fun with it you know like
like let poopies shine he'll make great
videos yeah and uh we really want to
support you thanks thanks um is there
anything that you won't do he will not
show nud nudity that's it only because
Cameo will you want to see the nud go go
to sto's video niio go to the
Nudo if you guys want to see my wiener
butthole go to sto's video and check out
the cameos I I I don't have that dude
huh I'm not putting he blurred it well
yeah it's
blurred see still yeah you can see still
see what's going on you know see what
we're talking about yeah see what we're
talking about um now uh see what we're
talking about you told us that you've
been um applying for jobs yeah yeah cuz
like the bank account's getting low and
I don't want to get too low you know
where I'm like
stressing I'm sure there's somebody
listening that would love to hire
poopies so I'm I'm good at
construction I love doing construction
work and um yeah if there's anyone out
there that what kind of construction
work do you do I'll just do do whatever
dude I I used to frame houses really you
know how a frame yeah I used to do it
all like I built track homes in Lacosta
those track homes
um by the VES right there on El Camino
all those track homes I was a part of
but yeah I
mean whatever you guys need I can learn
fast and you're uh setting up Christmas
lights yeah I applied for a Christmas
light in installation how much are you
charging for that I don't know I have a
interview next week oh it's not your own
business no I'm pretty sure people would
love just to hire you for to go around
and do it so so he they can DM you he
applied for installing Christmas lights
did you apply for the UCLA grounds
keeper no that just popped up but you're
going to apply yeah yeah yeah you dude I
don't think you need to apply any I
apped I made phone calls today um
there's a a lifeguard needed at the
Redondo high
school so I called theud you don't want
to do that [__] I know I know what about
on camera Cera stuff like you're you're
incredible on camera well everyone's on
strike right now yeah but you could
they're about to settle they're close to
settling but like you're on YouTube cont
you're not on strike pal yeah you're not
on stri YouTube
podcast I'm ready to send it I'm ready
to work it's good to be ready to work
and when I'm ready to do the important
work of keeping my lady satisfied in the
bedroom I take a blue chew why because
it's the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Calis except it's delicious
chewable and only costs a fraction of
the price and it helps me get that work
in baby all the way in and when I chew
my blue Cho tablet my tongue becomes
blue I show it to my lady Lux she
screams and that's because she knows I'm
getting ready to do that work and I'm
getting ready to do it well and if you
want to give this a shot I recommend it
because it's a lot of fun then the good
news is bluechew is offering you an
entire month's supply of blue Cho
tablets absolutely for free all you pay
is five bucks for shipping now how do
you get this deal you go to bluechew.com
use the promo code steo you consult with
the medical provider online boom you got
your prescription in a matter of moments
and that entire month supply is on its
way to you absolutely for free all you
pay is five bucks for shipping and when
that package arrives
Man chew it up and get to work that's
right have a good time too blu.com use
the promo code steo now let's get back
to it but yeah my YouTube videos I got
like YouTube videos stacked but I don't
want to put them out without like
YouTube sponsors you know I don't know
I'm just not not settling for for that
anymore yeah that's good I want to get
um a paid sponsorship for my YouTube
videos are you sponsored as like a
surfer or like within surfing pit viper
yeah okay cool yeah um you said that you
found a sponsor in the dog shock caller
yeah the dog shock caller and I they're
like what's your rate I was like well to
have you in my video and do product I
say it on this it was yeah don't give
away I think it sounded like gave them a
very reasonable quote and they came back
with something unreasonably low I'm
comfortable saying that shockingly low
yeah yeah so shot call thank you but
honestly I I think like I I think you're
going to get a lot of DMS from this for
people that know of jobs that you can
work they would love that dude you're a
great guy to have around thanks and uh
especially now like now like you're
reliably like employable yeah he's clean
and sober clear
he's a good looking man he's got a
girlfriend stop just absolutely lovable
that's one thing we were we were editing
together The Cameo video and Scott was
like man poopies is just
so
genuine inent and well cuz you really he
was like dude I just feel so bad about
the family like he he he had the Manina
going but like he just really felt bad
about the funeral like that was the
thought yeah like you could see the
empathy The Compassion oozing out of
your
Manina D the best part yeah we didn't
even put that in there but you were just
like just kidding yeah yeah yeah oh and
the one where I had that chick's ass
hostage we didn't even include that in
the video um this is the one where we
sent poopies a request the very first
request we sent said uh we want you to
um
re read this script say I have your
daughter and I will harm
her and your girl was screaming in the
background yeah she was in the shower
like help that was a funny touch that
was funny yeah like you just made it too
casual and and yeah that one wasn't good
I was just getting warmed up we were
just getting warmed up too you know that
was my first one exactly that one didn't
make the cut it was nothing to do with
you so yeah I kept getting these cameos
I was like dude I was like they're
getting better and better
well people like people should also know
they can send you like not just things
to say or like a birthday wish like
you'll do like sort of stunts like yeah
I can do I can do stunts I mean it just
like
dep not too gnarly of a stunt you know
it's not like yeah if you raise you know
tip me a little bit I'll maybe step it
up you know little tip on
there but yeah there's those business
ones too yeah you can do all kinds of
cameos mhm those business ones look kind
of nice yeah I mean if you want to set
your uh your business rate my business
rate's high right
now yeah yeah um tell us about your girl
oh my girl oh I love her so much um
Hannah
May um I could FaceTime her right now
she uh she's the best she um so I first
met her on Bumble when in Carl's Bad um
a year and two months ago and I put on
my profile that I was sober and I was
not
sober timate catfish I was living in the
U-Haul eating cat food you know what I
mean what you eating cat food say I
wasn't eating no I'm just joking um but
um yeah so we met and we matched and she
kind of knew something was going on you
know you were smoking meth at this time
mhm okay did you pick her up in the
U-Haul she came in the U-Haul and hung
her out before she she went in the back
of the box truck yep what did you have
in there like a couch like N64 out dude
I so I had I put 2x4s right cuz there's
these little wood things on the side
that you can tie stuff to so I put
2x4s on the half half of the backside
and put a plywood down and put a bed up
there but there's only this much room
from the bed to the top of the to the
ceiling claustrophobia yeah I never
slept in it and um and then I put a
couch like an L couch in there in the
back damn ni and then I had like
everything bungeed up and like had my
like tools and stuff and then like I'd
have my like motorcycle tweaking balls
dude just everything's organized and
bungeed yeah everything cuz I was mobile
you know so so it was kind of like a
little living room
and then it would like I put carpet down
and then I put um I had this baby
changer and that was like my table would
you stole it from like Burger King
no I found in like some like trash pile
cuz they're like demolishing this like
restaurant or whatever so I just found
it you know on trash that for just like
a table to put food and stuff on oh my
God so when you're showing Hannah this
place for the first time like what do
you kind of
like she's like I'm not going in there
like it's going to look like a meth adct
lives in here but he doesn't for sure
not I don't know you got to get her on
the Pod for that one I don't know what
she was thinking but my crib is kind of
messy I wasn't expecting company uh but
we first met when I had my apartment oh
okay all right so I had a studio when we
first met and and then you lost it all
then I lost it all and she's like what's
going on with you you know know and I
didn't want to tell her and she knew
something was going on and then I
freaking lost Grom one day and I your
dog yeah and then I put posters up in
and saying lost dog in Carl's Bad
Village and one of her friend saw it and
took a picture of it and sent it to her
and she called me and she's like what
the [__] like you lost Grom like she was
more worried about Grom than me what
happened to Gro um I found he was at the
pound I got him out of the pound
but um I rehomed him okay yeah cuz once
I got sober I was like dude I can't take
care of a dog right now I'm like in
recovery you know first first stages of
recovery so I I he's with a friend of
mine stinky Richard nice
so poopies and stinky Richard he's with
stinky Richard but yeah stinky Richard
loves him like he's they've known each
other since gr was a baby and I just
want him to be loved you know you know
yeah so he's he's he's be he's got a
good owner that loves him to death and
takes care of him so why are you living
in Playa why aren't you living down in
in North County um just cuz of recovery
dude like I don't want to be like in my
hometown you know yeah I got stomping
ground yeah it's just like when when you
get sober you got to change everything
dude your friends your your lifestyle
your your home you know your your town
that you live in like I had to change
everything mhm if I want to stay sober
you know so I take my my recovery
serious like I don't want to go back to
that life and like I so I have to change
you know and I have to change my life
and so and yeah that's kind of why we
moved to P Del re and Hannah's always
wanted to move to pad Del re since she's
a little little girl it's a nice area
yeah it's chill super quiet and and my
my um the house or the manager
maintenance guy is he's in recovery too
small world yeah so he's Super Rad older
guy Tom he has a band and stuff he's
super cool have you thought about making
putting a ring on
it yeah how R you want to cut that out
no she she knows I I've already got the
engagement ring oh wow did she know that
she kind of knows it I told her like I
put a down payment for it and like it's
getting
like like made you know what I mean
because her size her size is like a
three and a half super tiny so you can't
just go to like zel's and get a ring for
you know you got to get it custom so my
friend at Barnett jewelry is uh making
her a ring but I just got to you know
find the right place to drop the knee
you
know yeah so I'm just waiting for that
I'm not going to do it on my surf tour
in Hawaii I'm like you know what I mean
so right you just want to make sure that
you're
stealth yeah I want to surprise her you
know so she keeps asking like where's I
just want it now you know what I mean oh
she says she wants the ring now
yeah wow so she I mean she wants to get
married to you now yeah yeah she she
wants to get married which is so cool
like she puts up with me you know and
like not a lot of people can do that you
know well and she stayed with you
through this like downward she's like
the ride or die you know what I mean she
is the one sleep with you in the in the
U-Haul no no no once I lost my apartment
she kind of we kind of like we were
talking but we weren't really hanging
out you know you paid like 20 bucks a
day for the U-Haul yeah 20 bucks a day
my bill came out to like 1,800 bucks at
the end of it it was like a month and a
half yeah it was kind of just like
paying rent yeah kind of
yeah just electricity
water oh yeah I mean sleep in your own
sewage and come to think of it as kind
of a bad
deal for sure where were you like where
would you [__] like I saw a video you
you was I was [__] in like shoe
boxes okay I saw think about you
[__] in shoe boxes yeah or like I'd
use my Dad's apartment okay that's good
wait what was your rock
bottom it New Year's not the U-Haul or
shitty
it was charger phone charger San Jose
homeless begging for change who's the
how did the guy take your
U-Haul were you hanging out with him
before yeah we were supposed to go up to
Sacramento to get a van and turn in my
U-Haul so I could live in his van and by
Van you mean meth no so this guy I was
with I never did drugs with him really
yeah but he was on something like I
don't know if he was taking pills or
whatnot but I never did drugs with him
and like I think he was like kind of
manic and like a little bit out there
you know yeah and you were just hanging
out with them up there well I seen him
at State Beach at my L at the parking
lot in State Beach yeah and then you're
like oh dude what up yeah he kind of
like he you know kind of like he kind of
like thinks he's a rapper how long did
it take for you guys to hang out for him
to steal from you to steal the U-Haul
the the U-Haul got taken because I was
staying at a friend's house and this guy
I was with in the U-Haul cuz I I was
like just hop in my U-Haul you know
we'll go up to Sacramento and grab his
his van he had on his
property and um so he was overstaying at
a friend's house in San Jose and the my
friend worked at 6:00 a.m. in the
morning so I stayed the night there he
went to the U-Haul to sleep in the
U-Haul and I came out that morning and
the U-Haul was gone wow and you never
saw it again again he turned it in for
me oh where he took all my stuff out and
turned it in oh so he did you a huge
favor yeah oh kind of yeah oh okay but
then he didn't though because he wasn't
answering his phone he left me on the
streets well how'd you get back home he
finally came with a Suburban he got from
his property in Sacramento with all my
stuff in it and picked me up at this
hotel cuz I called my dad I was like Dad
I'm [__] stuck in San Jose he got me
a hotel that night so I wasn't freezing
in the streets and then the guy finally
came dude the guy never freaking slept
and I never did drugs with the guy I was
like what is this guy on dude and he
freaking drove to Sacramento and back to
San Jose dropped off the U-Haul put all
all my stuff in his
suburban and picked me up the next day
and we drove back to Carl's Bad and
that's when I've reached out for
help Jesus Christ wow so wait he woke up
maybe he just woke up he was was like on
meth and he was like I'm not waiting for
this guy to wake up I'll just do the
trip on my own yeah it was weird though
cuz I never like we never did meth
together I don't know what he was on but
he's just not a sharer like like your
other bro he probably just closet
tweaker like I'm not going to let him
know I I have some he's gonna smoke it
all what was Hannah doing when you were
going through all that um she was not
talking to me um yeah so and then I so
then when I lost Grom
back to the Grom story when I lost Grom
her friend sent her a picture of the
lost lost dog thing and she called me
where's Gro I go I lost them and then I
found him and then she's like I want to
like I was at State Beach and she was
like down the street I guess and she
came and saw me and that's when she's
like you need like you need to tell me
what's going on like I was like all
right well I've been freaking on meth
for the last eight months and she's like
I knew you're on something like and then
she's like if you want want to be with
me you need to get professional help and
you need to freaking go to rehab and
like get your [__] together
MH so she's a rider die she's a rer die
so she's been through the whole me
freaking being in a U-Haul to now where
I'm sober and she's the best she
supports my sobriety
100% And yep we have a great life now
yeah and I just I support whatever she
wants to do and yeah we love each other
very very much so what's going on with
your surfing surfing I'm ripping yeah is
your shark bite hand in the way of your
surfing no no it's it's good it just you
know so your shark bite hand is kind of
messed up for the rest of your life
there's no way around yeah like it
doesn't like I made sure like it bends
up so I can stand up but it doesn't bend
down you know right so it's good for
surfing but bad for everything else good
for surfing just bad for like putting
stuff in the like my backpack like you
know when you reach around put your
water bottle in there or something or
like weird like positions where you
can't really like can you twist it like
okay that's good dude your hand got
mangled mangled that was gnarly dude I I
think about it every day you have dreams
about it no thank God how many views is
the shark attack on your YouTube channel
last time I looked it was 1.7
million we made Banger yeah and I was
like how do I get another million
million view um video you got one more
hand I think we can I think we could do
well uh what's the one that didn't you
and I have one like uh your 10 oh yeah
the 10 most um that's like Nar narus
land stunts that's at like 600,000 good
what about uh did you ever do the water
stunts you got the 10 Gnar land stunts
yeah I know but Red Bull has all that
footage and I can't get all the footage
from Red Bull well isn't it just on
YouTube it's licensed yeah but you can
use uh Fair usage law oh really yeah can
you explain fair usage law okay um sorry
I just I think no that's good cuz people
hear about it a lot but it's we talk
about it a lot too and I'm like I'm
uncertain that I know what it is fair
usage um it was
uh it it was determined that when people
copyright footage that it's kind of not
fair that uh that they can just tie it
up and and preclude anybody from from
using it when
if you use copyrighted footage in a way
that is providing commentary like you
know Chang the meaning of it yeah like
you can't just take it you can't just
take somebody else's copyrighted footage
and just like put it as is somewhere
else but if you're commenting on it oh
if you're adding narrative if you're
using that uh copyrighted material to
illustrate a point to make a point then
uh the law was made that you're allowed
to do that like uh so poopies can make a
video commentating on the actual
absolutely that falls under Fair usage
law if if poopies is if poopies is going
to take Red Bull's copyrighted footage
and make his own video where he's adding
commentary to describe how and why these
were the gnarliest 10 STS see that's
great you should do that yeah how do you
pull that footage out that's why that's
how we make all of my top 10 craziest
shark Encounter videos top 10 I thought
the fair usage law was because you were
in it you could do that for yourself I
didn't realize it was for commentating
no it's really got nothing to do with
that I mean it probably protects you
because it's like I can give unique
commentary like I'm in it I can tell
maybe if it came to like some kind of a
decision but when we go and make the the
the one about the Nar the gnarliest ever
thing that we're working on I'm not in
any of that but we'll be able to do it
commentating yeah that's true yeah yeah
exactly how do you pull that footage out
of there I'll show you poops there's
like webites you can use burn Bridges
with
Jack um no he was a good guy for he was
good he was good I just couldn't afford
him yeah you know yeah we always liked
him the biggest problem was that he's
allergic to dogs and try to get me
anywhere without a dog yeah yeah now we
got two we've never had two dogs in the
in the van before I still talk to him
and stuff cool yeah right here like we
should mentioned that Lucy here she came
from Hawaii dude oh really so we got her
we got Lucy here um what's her full name
uh Lucy Louie Lucy L what's up how old
is she uh she just turned two oh nice
still Baby Oh Sister yeah we were on a a
trip to Hawaii we were in Kawaii and she
came from Kawaii Humane Society no way
what's up and the Kawaii Humane Society
has a dope thing where um they've got
like a deal with the airline so if
you're a tourist in Kawai who lives in
Mainland America um and you want to get
a dog free of charge they will ship that
dog on the airline to your city and in
America no way yeah we didn't have to
pay for anything they flew Lucy
L
flew her to LA and we picked her up at
the airport in La that's so rad and
she's since become uh a service animal
wow that must have been hard she
she I hate this mustache dude I really I
like it I mean dudes like it but like
it's just a little creepy yeah I mean
you look like big you look like the Sher
it's not been getting in the way of you
putting numbers on the board dude I'm
just getting bullied for getting
[__] no it's good you you look good
with the mustache all dudes are like I
love the mustache and then it's like
chicks are just like stay away from me
pervert um I'm just kidding that's not
the case so uh you've been doing your
podcast still yeah doing my podcast
shittiest podcast shittiest podcast ever
just had Jim jeffre on has that not been
published you put out yet no no I'm
trying to wait for podcast sponsor I got
all this stuff like in the hard drive
but I'm just trying to find sponsors do
it the right way you know what I mean
trying to get paid maybe if you uh
consistently put the podcast out and get
the numbers up higher that would be the
better way to attract the sponsors I
know and I've done that though yeah but
I think like you would you can just be
by yourself on the podcast so like
consistency is going to be your friend
because you're a funny guy like even
doing
commentating on videos like we you know
for the fair use law like dude I would
love to hear you give your take on the
news or current events dude yeah I mean
yeah what was it Philip def Franco he
put him to shame for sure yeah oh I had
um oh I just you were on Zach's podcast
how did that how did that Zach's podcast
was sick I think Zach is uh Zach's a
creative guy I think that he he did a
good job um as a podcast host I watched
your episode with him oh
sick yeah we just went to um the
Universal
Studios um scare SC Fest or something or
whatever they horror going go there
Saturday sick yeah we went to the Chucky
one oh they have different ones yeah
there's Chucky and there's the ones with
all the universal monsters oo it was
cool this one freaking Chucky comes out
and he's they spray water out of his
mouth I was like Chucky just spit on me
what the [__] so what you and Zach went
together yeah nice like after the
podcast MH what about a podcast like two
bears kind of thing like you and Zach do
a podcast together or something yeah I
think he just wants to do his own thing
yeah that's cool which I would I was
thinking about getting dark shark on my
podcast and having him be my co-host for
sure have you been in regular contact
with Zach yeah and and he's doing good
yeah he's got a um show tonight at The
Improv in Orange County oh wow cool he's
stand up is he who's he with is he solo
no there he's in a roster yeah cool yep
and then he's going I forget where he's
going but he's going somewhere and then
he'll be back um like November 5th or
something or the first he was at he
hosted the main stage of the Gathering
of the jug Zach did when recently this
past year and and I asked him um did you
show the Jugos your
butthole cuz that's what they do they
scream shorts your butthole yeah and his
response was so great he goes no I butt
chugged
Foo
wow bravo bravo Zach that's a good one
that's Marly he but chugged
Veo that Z so funny his standup was
really cracking me up by the time this
comes out does your secret mission
speaking of ICP does that come out yet
um I don't know no I don't think so not
quite but can we talk about it I mean
you talked about it Rec your rap song
dog I oh really it's kind of the sickest
rap song cuz didn't you just post
something that your rap career failed
yes and
now thank you for bringing that up yes
and now I am redeeming myself it's a rap
Redemption dog let's go yeah it's a sick
ass song sick I want to get on the track
I mean there will be more tracks let's
go yeah he's Spitting Fire right now
really I am I don't I don't mean the
brag but he's Spitting Fire right now
[__] let's go yeah that's been that's
been a fun I mean we've been filming
content so like your YouTube channel get
ready cuz it's going to go off we've
been we've been hitting it pretty hard
man cuz now my tour is over and I'm like
I'm not on the road like what am I going
to be doing I just just kind of like go
you have any good ideas y for for for
footy yep I I want to I want to do some
like stunts cuz my stunts get the most
views mhm you know I got this idea where
you know you take you know those
mechanical things that guys lay on they
go underneath the car with yeah mhm take
that down a hill backyard luing sick
wear a helmet San Francisco uh there's a
hill right by my house yeah it goes
straight down but you just got to watch
out for the
cars well aren't you going to go
underneath them
no by Design you would go underneath it
that would bean gnarly Clips your nose
you just freaking lose your face um I I
would ask um that you figure out a way
to make it funny cuz just bombing the
hill yeah like well it's all it's all
about the leadup you know like getting
it out of my garage like I've been
looking at this hill for the last two
months now
right and and I think that you could get
really worked and have it not even like
necessarily be that funny where like
maybe it's more of like a like a prank
kind of a situation you know like where
you have some like some some situation
where you can roll out from underneath
something yeah you know I got a garage I
got a garage in the
alley yeah like what like the whole
video you're like rolling out from under
stuff like under a vending machine like
when someone goes buy something like you
roll out like can you hand me the
screwdriver or like something like that
like all over different [__] that is a
good idea I mean I would just I I would
urge you to find ways to film funny
stuff more than like just stuff where
you can really get broken yeah that's a
really break one too for sure yeah like
our buddy Tanner who's always bombing
Hills it's like oh
man I get anxiety watching him yeah they
get the speed speed wobbles yeah dude
it's scary yeah so what what else is
going on man what what uh like you're
not mess around with any of that like uh
what was it called like poopies doobies
or something no that's over yeah that's
good man no no no more no more cannabis
nope it's good dude I'm clean and sober
I love that y I love that um what's your
favorite thing about being sober just
enjoying the moment the present yeah I
think mine are naps yeah cuz I was
daytime naps I napped I napped steo
called me today and I was napping and I
S I seen I just woke up from my nap and
I seen Miss call from steo and I was
like he's like come over I was like okay
I just woke up from nap but I'm on my
way yeah I like nap I like just like
being a better poopies sober
sex we don't talk I can't really talk
about that but I just like being sorry I
just like being a better poopy you know
I don't you know and I'm proud of that
yeah it's good to get through a day
knowing that you didn't make anybody
really mad at you yep mhm you don't feel
guilty all the time for no reason yeah
and I have selfworth that is the most
awesomest thing about sobriety is
selfworth yep you know I love it yeah so
I've it's it's crazy what what um how
much work I've been doing um but yeah
there's there's all kinds of stuff I can
get into like you look different you
look healthy yeah my my chi got me on
all gluten-free diet yeah yeah so no
gluten um try not to eat like meat only
ground
turkey and just like no
lactose pretty good diet that's good
dude mhm and we're going to give a shout
out to pit viper y pper are they
throwing you a little bit loot yeah to
pit VIP can can they like buy like some
like poopies glasses or like we don't
have a signature model yet is there like
a discount code they can use by using
poopies I don't even think we have a
promo code we did but I don't know they
kind of just like stopped the promo code
but those are those rad glasses that you
always wear the like big ones that like
wrap around now nice Fu you scum dog
scum dog scum dog scummy deer scummy
Diner scummy deer I miss that guy dude
yeah yeah dude he's so funny but yeah
pit viper shout out um you got that that
uh pit viper bromo code the bromo code
yeah code
poopies just ask see what Happ yeah but
I just made it up just now I'll hit a
pper right now a week you got a week
that's good I thought you said bromos I
was stealing it from you no I that was
no comes out so I can tell him to make a
promo code yeah well there was that
thing Neil the grass text was like
thanks for saying that SC and you're
like what did I say like it was like a
whole thing you're like I don't even
remember what I said Neil the grass
Tyson's podcast like me and Steve were
just like two idiots in the back of the
classroom like huh like I couldn't even
understand what the [__] and you
understand everything it's cuz he's on
shrooms micro does that's true micro all
right dude well [__] uh anything else
poopies man can we can we give any love
can we give any support can we promote
any thing oh we want people to hire you
for odd jobs yeah sure yeah I need work
I do or Cameo reist work jobs M like
okay you're going to do receptionist
work okay yeah
secretary yeah nurses assistant that
yeah um you should at least film all
this [__] this is a YouTube series like
poopies does odd jobs like today I got
hired to like like as a bus boy bus boy
here we go and like film it and put it
out as a YouTube I need to get a filmer
any filmers out there we should reach
out to trip and be like was it Nitro
Circus in town can't you meet up with
them when they're in Anaheim and do
something crazy at the [__] I've been
trying to meet up with those guys for so
long I've been talking with um Beaver
Fleming yeah I think they're they have
like a a guest spot for for like a big
influencer to do something at their
Anaheim I I keep hitting up beaver and
he's like I'll hit you up I'll hit you
up but like I don't know it never got
back to me all right what were you going
to say
Steve say yeah we'll figure it out I I
love you poopies love you too everybody
hire poopies for jobs he'll do anything
order his
cameos support support poopies and yeah
thank you support his sobriety and
support his health yes and support his
life please all right [__] yeah dude
thank you for having me on again dude
love you appreciate it love you too boys
love you dude love you guys you're a
completely different person from the
last time we did the podcast it's good
to see for sure I'm a changed man dude
love you dude love you too no gluten No
[Laughter]
Mess a lovable young man poopies and man
a sad story too you got to just feel for
him I'm rooting for him and I want you
to know I appreciate you very very much
much uh as I sit here today um
celebrating the release of my bucket
list special if you haven't seen it
please please get over to sto.com and
support The Bucket List um I've
definitely been uh burning the candle at
both ends man I'm uh pretty pretty
burned out on all all the work I've been
doing but hey man it's worth it and
again please do check out the bucket
list ato.com
um other than that man my street team
people I love you and thank you and I'm
going to
bed all right